Yes.
Much lies yet you know. And.
Yeah. One would have hoped that.
Folks settling in this community would have
been enormously industrious to build a
low impact low demand sustainable lifestyle
planting permaculture across the
hillsides. Vegetable gardens
in the rich volcanic soil.
Learning skills to support
themselves economically.
I've not done any
scientific analysis of this
but it seems to me a third of the people
would make very little if any effort in
those directions at all and other third
makes. And other thirds quite industrious.
I say one would have hoped
because there's a crying need.
Across the planet for a low impact
low demand sustainable lifestyle.
To rein in the horrendous excesses
and waste of rampant consumerism
in the materialistic west.
That also to show a viable way
of fulfilling life to the
impoverished third world.
The sort of alternative society
which exists in pockets in
and around rainbow region. Does
bear these characteristics it does.
Show. A fireball future direction
for planetary civilization.
But
that matter first station has
been severely damaged by.
The one third who contribute nothing
and the 130 contribute only a little.
And.
Well as a lawyer i was not able to
practice without fear of employment
and was unable to gain employment locally
because of resentment from a very
conservative profession.
So i had to go to the gold coast to get
a job and polish up my skills again.
I have done that and and could move
back now set up my own practice.
But lacked the capital to really do so
and was so much children are going
to school on the gold coast now.
It's a lot of good things down here which
are very attractive living close to the
mountains growing one's own food.
The various aspects of alternative culture
which are so positive like home birthing.
The bush music scene. Alternative power.
Alternative healing.
It's a for it's a fine culture to live in
and develop a love harking
back to what i saying earlier.
I think that easy welfare. And.
The tractions of black market
marijuana growing and dealing.
Which has had a spin off with
considerable portion of of heroin users
and white powder. Been a
fetter mean type users.
Of the downside of
that positive culture of course those
downsides exist throughout society there have
been limited to this one.
That the shame of it is
the enormous national
and planetary need for this sort of.
Low impact low demand lifestyle to be
evidence in a thoroughly positive way.
And one would have hoped after 20 years
a lot more would have been achieved
and has been.
I found it at the time rather.
Airy fairy and hedonistic.
But i hope that people would be able
to implement that idealism into nuts
and bolts reality of homes and orchards
and local industries and craft.
For the first five or ten
years. Folk would say.
Oh where shell shocked from being in the
world outside we need to turn inwards
and observe nature and get some sort
of centering on what we're going to do
and why and i kept saying that for another
five years. I think after 20 years.
With really got to bridge the gap
between the intellectual ideals
and the nuts and bolts physical reality.
In australia which is going
down the chute economically.
That's not good enough to keep putting
one's hand out to the public purse.
No doubt there's a.
Horrific rich poor gap in australia
which justifies the economically
underprivileged sections
receiving some welfare
and no doubt the receipt of
that welfare relieves
revolutionary type pressure on
that 10 per cent which controls
90 per cent of the wealth.
Welfare as a good and just thing in
the present economic arrangement.
But once criticism must go to the
present political economic arrangement.
It's preserving this rich poor gap.
It's preserving enormous waste of
energy in government and bureaucracy.
It's my thesis
that by adopting a more
decentralized system
with. Political power maximized in local
areas. And economic independence.
Maximise as much as possible in the local
areas so as to obviate the need for
transportation.
So a lot of this wastage of
money on central government
and the
concentration of wealth in a
few hands can be avoided.
There's a sink simple one simple answer to
australia's economic political imbalance.
And that is to replace all taxation.
With site revenue site revenue should
be a sole source of public finance
site revenue is a collection of the only
all mental value of sites privately
occupied whether those sites
be on land and water or. Yeah.
Whether those sites be used for
residence commercial industrial public
or any other use. The only sites which
should be free of paying site revenue.
Would be there
and which is truly open to the
public at any time such as roads.
National parks beaches.
Land which is held by government
bodies such as ministries
or local government including church land.
All of
that should pay the annual rental value
of the site occupied to the community.
This would force down
the price of land such
that land would eventually transfer only
for the value of improvements upon it
would be a severe disincentive to people
owning more land than they have to.
Would make a lot of land available for
the present unemployed folks to settle
and pioneer survivor lifestyles
like their forefathers did.
Because workers would have this choice of
independence on their own. Smallholding.
So there'd be competition for labor
and rewards for labor would
naturally be high without the.
Necessity for union action.
No longer would there be the
massive imposts upon effort
and creativity which income tax
paid roll tax stamp duties.
Financial institution taxes and horror
of horrors the proposed g s.t..
Embroil any industrious
person in suffering.
That's a simple solution
site revenue. Rate.
And. I think.
There has been good advances
on various cultural fronts.
Such as community based pre-school
ing and primary schooling.
Home birthing bush music.
Alternative power.
There are good examples of permaculture.
And so subsistence.
I'd say it's gone a decent way down the
track in evidencing what's possible.
Although to me personally the progress
has been sadly inadequate for where we
should and could have been
at this time. You know.
Reality is not in the way
or. I just shooting for.
Oh.
Yes it could it could it
could be the hard knocks.
Is this really it is difficult to
struggle with inadequate capital to build
and plant.
It's. So easy to get any.
Caught up in in the effort of day
to day living family tensions.
The sheer problems of living hard in an
area like this with without often without
electricity and with heavy rainfall.
And many people can't afford.
The basic price of a share in land which
is usually gone far beyond the original
$200 which total loss telling totals
now about twelve or fifteen hundred.
With difficult conditions
of. Approval to me.
Met before any shares granted.
Really they could and
should have been dozens
or scores of large scale community
settlements like tata bull.
That the high price of land
has made that difficult.
There was one effort several years
ago tiam akari on the kayak
or road where the new south wales.
Department of i think it was housing.
Assisted in setting up a low
impact low demand type. Community.
With with subsidised.
Share prices which could be paid back
over a period even by someone receiving
welfare. Unfortunately
that whole exercise was severely damaged
by one element of settlers who wanted to
grow marijuana which was obviously
contrary to the mandate
or franchise a state government had
entrusted to those steering the community.
And then if a change of government
and the new south wales liberals
quickly ended the adventure.
But to answer your question.
There's a lot of physical difficulties
in fulfilling the ideals.
That in a world which is suffering such
threats to its continued existence from
pollution poverty unemployment
economic illness.
It's incumbent upon every one of us
to keep those ideals in me. Find.
To our best to achieve it
and not cut down as being
abnormally tall poppies.
Other individuals who.
Exhort folk to aim at those ideals
and even.
Exhort them to cease wasting the
potentials we have such crying planetary
and national need to achieve those ideals.
Well i think my favorite memory
happens every dawn and dusk
when the stillness
descends on this valley.
And the birds and all their
incredible variety and richness.
Call their their clear sounds back
and forth.
Something. Yes definitely.
The mandala mountain around mount warning
attracted me here to settle.
You may be aware
that the amount warnings the highest
mountain in eastern australia.
Receives the first sunlight of
a dawn touching this continent
and it's a plug of an ancient volcano.
The rim of that ultra
and volcano is the nightcap range here in
the south where tuttle is the tweed range
in the west and the macpherson
range along the queensland border.
So if you look at it on a broad scale contour
map you're see a veritable circle of
mountains. Centred on mount. Morning.
So if it for 20 years.
I saw this is actually a mandala
terrain of a cross which and you
and civilization could be
built. And demonstrating.
A valuable way of life for
the rest of the nation
and the globe can expand on that and.
Chris i think i mean.
There is an infinite consciousness.
Some might call it god
or buddha.
I think jesus christ was a true
individual who. Free thoroughly.
Into the highest extent embodied that.
Consciousness.
Is not something one can
intellectualize very well.
That living close to nature.
Growing one's own food.
You know i've been happy and
felt at peace with the universe.
And that's all the spiritual
insight i require.
And things
that.
I can take on the 6th of december 1990.
No kind of.
Health care like.
Someone told me it's some
indonesian for sewa.
Straight. But.
A camera and soft technology engineers
pictures and carly mclachlan and.
I'm very busy working for
rainbow power at the moment
but i still live in this community as i've
done for 19 years now. That adjustors.
And i first came to nimbin
for the queerest festival
when i came up with a wonderful
contingent of 10 hippies for minute knee
and we brought with us
a prefab recanted dome
and put it up on the
paddock the side of nimbin
and we had an unbelievably
amazing two weeks.
It was self like a dry run for what could
be possible in the way of soft technology.
And it worked nicely. With a
wonderful time and the. The bamboo.
Jam tin and plastic dome
which is quite big.
We eventually sacked totally
and with thatching on it made a
perfectly respectable building.
We had a fireplace in the
middle and that's all around it
and it was a bit like a tepee you know back
buckminster fully tepee was a concept.
What i consider getting around it.
Music was a bit of a broke
revival thing starting.
And also the celtic revival and there's
a great spirit of ancient momentum
that was happening at that stage
and we had in anderson from the
doors playing bach. Minuets.
Interspersed with rock music
it was i guess you'd call it.
Broken celtic infusion of the
rock music which is a driving.
Anti-society force at that stage and
being a musician of some sort. I was.
Only interested attracted by
this expression of culture.
The idea was to somehow have the best of.
City culture while the best
of country like environment.
And if you somehow mix both together
then you'd be really in paradise.
And on top of that because the
ideal of political autonomy.
Been a lot of political repression
at that stage and very much.
This utopian movement of the 60s and 70s
was a response to political repression.
A lot of very straight laced notions
in the way to legislature at
that stage was set up and most of us had
been on the wrong side of the law over.
Everything from drinking in public smoking
marijuana right through to conscription.
So we had very little time
very establishment either law
or police
and i was a totally respectable
mathematics teacher.
I'd tried to become a physicist and
i wasn't quite in the top notch.
Group of students enough to to achieve
that i ended up becoming a teacher is the
only way of financing myself through
university.
I became a teacher but not a very
good one and eventually decided
that educating people for destructive
and non-existent jobs was.
You know limited potential i thought
that create a changing things much
more fundamentally than simply
and educating people in school to
tolerate the system was more practical.
How long after. Not long. And
six months i came here to live.
I since the festival i'd started.
I'd actually before the festival i
decided i was going to live in the north
and rivers commune. The
only questions which one.
I've been up at elance which is right close
to my home looking to settle in there
and.
Didn't feel very welcome at any of the
communists which were being set up up
and down the coast at that time
and the aquarius movement had much more
political strength integrity to it than any
of the previous which were really
just like extended family groups.
And for that reason i joined this commune.
What was it about the book.
It was big at a certain
inertia to it that meant
that personality issues didn't end up
dominating the politics and the ideology.
And in that way the political process
and the corporate structure of this place
were very superior to anything else which
had happened. It gave much
more rights to the individual.
That emerged to.
No because it was never
excessively applied.
I think i can think of many cases where
this community only stayed together because
of its political structure and there
are lots of parallels with other.
Communes at the same
time which didn't have
that political structure
which fell apart and
when the necessary conflicts of
interest turned up there with the forum
and the communication in this
come into to sort out things.
So when we we faced all of
the the big issues that
that any intentional community
faces which is. Work obligations.
Impact on neighbors sharing
resources and ironically
that gets translated into reality
is guns dogs and fences.
That's the bottom line of. Of a conflict.
Often that's just a symptom
of the underlying conflict
but that's where it always bubbles out
and our community did a better job of
managing those subjects than many of the
others with less structure.
That water politics and.
Yes it. Well yes and.
That politics and water politics were not.
Issues
that the corporate structure of the commune
dealt with more regional issues is
that i think possibly for that
reason they got much more nasty
and more involved with
personal power politics.
Rather than with overall
principles and guidelines
and the seems to be.
It's where the individual comes
up against the community.
I think when issues of
water and doper involved
and dope of course was a
financial ticket. It was.
A very quick and easy way
of getting money which is
that thing which is most
short in supply here. And.
The dole was equally powerful but
that didn't really impinge nearly so much
on the community structure was water
and dope.
Both were strong incentives for people to
work in an actively anti-social manner
for their own gain. And
that's what happened.
I think so yes. With water.
It was come compounded by the fact
that most people don't
understand how water works.
It's intellectually difficult particularly
for people with dope addled brains
and i think most of the what is seen as
blatant unbelievable self-interest was
actually not quite as simple as that but.
Really a combination of
self-interest and confusion
and a tendency to paranoia. In other words
you assume that if there's no water.
It's your neighbor's fault rather than
because there's an airlock in the pipe
and i think it's something
deep in your mind nature to
when our fundamental resources are
threatened either land or water.
We immediately try to blame somebody.
Rather than to look at what the
real problem is it's instinctive
and people tended to have a lot of i was
here first type of mentality. Who's water.
That shift to a place where
there was a reliable stream
and then be unwilling to share
it. Not realising that water.
Is really very much public property.
I mean even in mainstream australia it's
public property except out west where you
can buy and sell water rights
but they aren't you can't
just sort of grab water.
Times and events.
All right from the beginning i saw a
problem in that people were taken out of.
What it called a fully serviced
environment in the suburbs
and dropped in orbit very
beautiful surroundings
but surroundings in which nearly all of
the fundamental surfaces were missing.
And suddenly the issues of
well let's run through them.
No sewage pipes no water pipes no roads.
No phone lines. No electricity.
Ok i think i've run through five
fundamental services or missing.
And it was very difficult for people to
accommodate to the enormous sudden drop in
their standard of living and they
were both psychologically unprepared
and physically unprepared to take
that step back in servicing level
and i could run through each one of
those five services and the mess ups
that happened as a result of people's
attempts to get away. To do without them.
And that i think it's a story
that this community as much as it's political
story as much as it's social story
the story of the effect of withdrawal of
services from people one instinct like
i've just mentioned is that
people for the fight for what.
What is so you get power politics
and territory power to. Politics.
Based on the roads.
The electricity which is here
and the other side of this you get people
suffering terrible deprivation through
not knowing how to get a.
On the lack of those services in the first
year we had a lot of the uman labor
being expended carrying
containers of water up hills.
People didn't realize
that there was actually abundant water
at high altitude here just a question of
knowing how to pipe it. But
that total lack of skill of dealing
with fundamental resources
and how to supply them for self
caused an awful lot of suffering.
Oh enormous we had houses burned
down by people using candles.
We had our first fatality on the property
i think was a baby but to death.
It was a second. Wasn't it. Anyway
the point is that we had deaths.
We had great suffering caused by people
not knowing how to do without services.
And this is all totally
foreseeable and expectable.
So a lack of electricity cause
people to get burnt to death.
Lack of communication caused people to die
of snakebite that's no telephones lack
of roads caused people to dive many
malnutrition in a couple of examples.
And. The snake death also was
related to lack of roads.
Lack of sewage caused to
have a type of outbreak.
I think one person died of that lack of.
Gone through them
or lack of water caused unbelievable
problems again with health
and with into neighbor conflict.
Coming from.
What i came from a very
practical background.
Because my father was a farmer and my
training was all in in physics and science
and i'd always been in the
canwick and things like that.
So i thought i came he was
a very good skills based.
I was given a few rude shocks early on by
the difficulty of making services work.
The first thing i did.
As run up a water pipe and found
that water would not run
down hill through a pipe
that was a bit of a shock to my
conception of how the world works.
Once i learned why there's a bit of a
learning curve thing with nearly everything
everything you have to do.
It took a little while to get
through those early setbacks
but soon we learnt to run water down
pipes. That all started working nicely.
And that's been the story really as last
20 years gradually getting alternative
services going to formulate.
Way. Getting into.
Them forming new.
I actually got interested in rainbow power
after the failure of my efforts to try
and provide servicing to this intentional
community. I had great plans for.
For doing soft impact. Transport.
Water electricity supplies
for the community
and i would call most of those a failure.
Partly on my own fault for under mr
underestimating the difficulties partly
that are the fault of
just not enough capital.
Partly the fault of people not having
confidence that these things could work
and the reactor.